thank you guys
right
it was
all right
this is my first briefing in the
administration
he wants
my friends
all right
okay
look at that oh cleal
oh cheers
hey hi everyone
hi good afternoon good afternoon
okay we have another special guest
joining us today uh secretary of
agriculture tom vilsack as you all know
this is secretary vilsack's second turn
at the department of agriculture which
led in the obama bin administration from
2009
to through 2017 making him the
longest-serving member of president
obama's
cabinet in those years secretary vilsack
fought to put americans back to work by
investing in rural infrastructure
renewable energy
and large-scale conservation
partnerships under his leadership
usda introduced healthier food choices
in school meals to benefit 50 million
children and expanded free and reduced
price lunches for millions of kids
prior to his appointment or nomination
and confirmation i should say secretary
vilsack serve two-term
governor of iowa in the iowa state
senate
and as the mayor of mount pleasant iowa
with that i will turn over to the
secretary
who will be take a few questions once he
concludes his remarks
jen thanks very much uh it's certainly a
pleasure to be here today
uh with all of you uh i'm here primarily
to talk about food and
nutrition security and you may think
that that is uh just about
uh food and nutrition security but in
fact it's about a lot more than that
when you understand that 25 of america's
workforce
is directly or indirectly impacted by
the food and ag industry
that it represents a significant
percentage of our gdp
uh that educational achievement is
somewhat dependent on youngsters having
healthy and nutritious food as they
begin their school year and school day
and the fact that it is a a noted effort
in reducing the
food nutrition security becomes an
important issue
and certainly we've seen the impact of
that during the course of the pandemic
when the american rescue plan was
enacted
hunger in the united states was at 15
percent of our population
which was an incredibly high number
today
as a result of the investments under the
american rescue plan
we now know that hunger has dipped to
eight percent
of america's population that's a
remarkable uh drop in a six-month period
it is a result of extending snap
as we did in the american refugee plan
creating a summer
ebt program that will institute
opportunities for
a nearly 30 million children to have
action
summer months increasing our commitment
to wic
uh and basically uh making a a down
payment if you will
on hunger reduction uh we have the
opportunity
over the course of the next several
months as congress considers the
american
job plan and the american family plan to
cement
those uh those results and to actually
build upon them
there are three key investments for
nutrition and food security
uh in the american families plan first
we're going to make permanent uh this
incredible and historic effort
to feed kids during the summer months
there are as i said nearly 30 million
american children who are in free and
reduced lunch status
in schools at the end of the school year
there is no
uh program other than the summer feeding
program which impacted and affected
several million
of those 30 million children now we have
the opportunity
to provide each one of these families
with a card that looks like this
this is the summer ebt card that's
available
it allows parents the opportunity to go
to the grocery store as they do with
their snap card
and be able to purchase additional
fruits and vegetables and other
wholesome food for their children
ensuring that 30 million kids
will have the opportunity to have
nutrition during the summer which means
that they'll be
better prepared to begin school ready to
learn in the fall
we're also extending with this effort
the opportunity to impact free school
meals in high poverty school areas by
focusing on the community eligibility
program that essentially identifies the
ability of a school district
where snap participation is roughly 40
percent
to extend free meals to everyone in that
school
this is going to expand opportunities
for youngsters to be well fed
and we know from a recent tough study
that one of the healthiest places in the
country for children to eat
is now in america's schools so we're
going to see that extended and we're
going to focus with a
a specific laser-like focus on
elementary schools to make sure that our
youngest learners
uh have the best possible opportunity
and finally uh we're going to uh
in a billion dollars congress is open
assistance uh
in trying to figure out strategies that
will improve even more than we already
have
the nutritional value and quality of the
meals that youngsters receive in schools
so these three steps these three key
investments
on the american families plan will allow
us to cement the gains under the
american rescue plan
and hopefully impact and reduce hunger
uh to the point eventually
one day where we won't have to have a
press conference about about hunger
so with that i'd be happy to take take
us
questions
yeah secretary both a couple questions
one about the
mines that you uh the mine project that
you had previously blocked
uh and then the uh trump administration
allowed those to open up
do you have any uh particular view on
whether that should be
reopened or not this is the twin metal
cover
mine uh there's always a very difficult
balance
to strike in any of these questions and
certainly in this particular one
you're balancing a pristine incredibly
important and valuable
uh natural site uh the boundary waters
of the mississippi
uh a tremendously uh unique
area it's one that the late walter
mondale
felt very strongly about and i i know
that
from a personal experience with the
former vice president he called me
repeatedly on this issue
so you've got that on one hand on the
other hand you obviously have jobs and
economic opportunity
and i think the challenge is to try to
see if you can strike a balance
and that's what we attempted to do in
the previous administration and i don't
see any reason
why we should why we should change that
calculation
uh trying to find the balance between
preserving a pristine area and at the
same time looking for ways in which
job growth economic growth can take
place in rural areas
and that's what we're going to attempt
to do there are no final decisions being
made on this this is obviously something
we also have to do in conjunction with
the department of interior they have a
us in this issue as well
i just want to get to a bunch of people
in here sure um
one way of increasing snap benefits is
by uh reforming the thrifty food plan
um and i know that that is under review
right now can you talk a little bit
about what
that review entails and when we should
expect
results and how the reforms would be
implemented if
the program is it's a complicated uh
question and one that hasn't been
reviewed in detail for quite some time
uh and we expect and anticipate during
the course of the summer months
uh that we will complete our review and
then have an opportunity perhaps to have
a conversation about this in the fall
and this will be appropriately timed uh
because as you know the american rescue
plan called for an extension of the
increase in snap
uh over the course of of the summer
months until the end of september
so it's timely for us to look at this
i'd simply say that the principles that
we're operating under
in this area are number one the the
benefit has to be meaningful
uh to american families with the
american rescue plan we saw an
additional
dollars a month for a family of four
being added to the groceries
uh to their grocery purchases it also
impacts jobs as i said before
uh that snap benefit increased uh and
supported tens of thousands of jobs in
grocery stores and
across the food chain it also has to be
conveniently available
it's one of the reasons why again the
american rescue plan has provided
opportunities for us to look at online
purchasing
make it more convenient it has to be
operated with integrity
obviously and it has to be we have to
look for ways in which we can incent and
encourage
those dollars to be used in in the best
way possible to but
provide the most nutritious benefit to
american families
uh and that's the goal and that's what
we'll look at when we look at the
the thrifty food plan secretary a group
of midwestern farmers last week
sued uh over the cobit uh a coveted loan
forgiveness program
arguing that uh it's unfair to them
because they're white uh your reaction
to that lawsuit and
you you stand by that the program's
structured it's a great question i
appreciate it
uh i think you have to take you back uh
20 30 years
when we know for a fact uh that socially
disadvantaged producers were
discriminated against by the united
states department of agriculture
we know this we have reimbursed people
in the past for those acts of
discrimination but we've never
absolutely dealt with the cumulative
effect and by cumulative effect i mean
this
when i have the full advantage of all
the usda programs
throughout the last 30 years my
operation could grow
i could invest in more land i could get
the latest and best
technology i could plant my crop at just
the right time
i could make more money if i had limited
access or no access
to usda programs obviously my operation
significantly limited so the american
rescue plan's
effort is to begin addressing the
cumulative
effect of that discrimination in terms
of socially disadvantaged producers
secondly when you look at the covert
relief packages that had been passed and
distributed by usda
prior to the american rescue plan and
you take a look at who
disproportionately received the benefits
of those covered payments it's pretty
clear that white farmers did pretty well
under that program
because of the way it was structured
it's structured on size and structured
on production
so i i think there is a a very
legitimate reason
for doing what we are doing i think it
has to be complemented with additional
steps
which the american rescue plan provides
an equity commission to take a look at
whether or not there are
systemic barriers that need to be
removed at the department
and and also uh taking a look at how we
might be able to
create better technical assistance
better access to
land uh better access to markets for
socially disadvantaged producers and for
local and regional
uh food production uh so uh we're going
to continue to proceed forward
uh and the litigation is going to be
what it is and we'll walk
we'll obviously have the department of
justice and others do what they do
but in the meantime the u.s department
of agriculture is going to move forward
with that effort thank you secretary
vilsack
you've just outlined the plans for the
arp
funds through the fall to deal with some
of the issues around
hunger how long do you anticipate those
funds will last particularly given that
next year's school year will be unique
coming off of the year where most
schools have been closed for the better
part of the year
and will you need more funds from
congress to address this well i think
that's
one of the reasons why the president
proposed the american families plan
as a continuation and as uh allowing us
to basically cement and
make more permanent the gains that we've
seen from the american rescue plan
in the meantime we have uh worked with
schools understanding they're faced with
uh
a lot of uncertainty about the upcoming
school year and so we have already
decided that we have
available resources to be able to
provide for universal free lunch
for schools throughout the 21 22 school
year
um and and that will extend i think
until the end of june 2022
with the passage of the american
families plan we would then have the
summer ebt program
to provide additional support and help
and that would give us i think enough
lead time for school districts to be
able to adjust
back to what the new normal will be in
the meantime we'll be looking at
hopefully the use of the pilot
under the american rescue under the
american families plan to see if there
are ways in which we can incent
additional nutritional value for those
meals and we'll be using hopefully with
the passage of the american family's
plan
a more targeted effort in high poverty
schools elementary schools to expand
universal
free free meals
on this idea of a carbon bank since
you've been on the job what is the
feedback that you've gotten
from farmers and is this something that
you think needs congressional approval
you know i was at a meeting yesterday
with the environmental protection agency
administrator
michael regan he did a terrific job we
had probably 25 farmers
i was very pleased with the level of
support and interest that the farm
community has
for ways in which they can be engaged in
this effort
to reduce emissions and to be engaged in
this climate effort
uh we had multiple questions about this
in terms of how can we do this not
we're against it or we're opposed to it
or we don't think it should happen
it was how can we do this how can we be
part of this because farmers understand
something very very fundamental about
this
this is the opportunity of a lifetime
for us to create
additional revenue opportunities for
farmers now why is that important
because today 89.6 of american farms
the majority of income does not come
from the farm for those farm families
that means they have to have an off-farm
income
so it's the department of agriculture's
job to find more better and new markets
climate provides that opportunity
whether it's a fund
or whether it's conservation resources
whether it's uh
investments in technology that will
allow them to capture methane and reuse
it
or whether it's creating new
opportunities for bioprocessing
and new jobs in rural places all of that
has to be done
and i think the usda has has enormous
capacity
an enormous set of tools that can be
used to provide the resources to work
with the farm community
to embrace this future and i think they
are in agreement with president biden
when he says the net goal here is net
zero emissions by 2050. i think that's
doable
and i think in doing it i think we'll
improve income opportunities for farmers
we'll certainly do right by the
environment and i think we'll also have
healthier and better soil and cleaner
water
a carbon bank well it needs a
congressional approval in a sense that
you have
resources in all of these programs that
require funding
we have a lot of flexibility already at
usda
and we're going to be utilizing that
flexibility
in a way that creates more new and
better markets and i think farmers are
going to find that
uh to be a very they're going to be very
agreeable with that thank you thank you
thank you and as always um if you all
have follow-up questions we are happy to
connect you with this team i'll follow
you thank you we'll love to have you
i'll just know my first campaign was for
the secretary's
um gubernatorial race in 2002 so
full circle um a couple of items
additional items for all of you at the
top
uh this afternoon uh president biden as
you know will deliver
remarks on amer the american rescue
plans restaurant revitalization fund the
administration's program to provide
relief to restaurants
bars food trucks and other food and
drink establishments
as we all know restaurants were some of
the first and worst hit
businesses in the pandemic the
restaurant revitalization fund provides
28.6 billion dollars in direct relief to
restaurants
and food and beverage establishments and
prioritizes those that are women owned
veteran owned and owned by other
socially and economically disadvantaged
individuals by only funding applications
from these businesses for the first 21
days
of the program then it expands beyond
there
earlier today the president also visited
one local restaurant that was a
beneficiary of relief
funding through the revitalization
fund's pilot program uh
taqueria jemelas i'm going to butcher
that and i apologize i want to go there
and have some tacos um
is owned in part by mexican immigrants
and during the pandemic went from 55
employees to just
seven so clearly uh in great need these
funds will allow business owners to
complete
delayed projects rehire and raise the
wages of their staff
pay their rent and operate with
confidence again
uh applications for the program opens up
on monday and in just the first two days
of the program
186 200 restaurants bars and other
eligible businesses in all 50 states
washington dc and 5 u.s territories
applied for
relief 97 600 applications came from
restaurants bars and other eligible
businesses
owned and controlled by women veterans
socially and economically disadvantaged
individuals
or some combination of three 61
700 applications came from businesses
with under five hundred thousand dollars
in annual pre-pandemic revenue
representing some of the sales
restaurants
and bar and businesses uh in america
um and uh we look forward to
implementing
that program uh with that i think we can
go alex to you
questions uh so the cdc summer camp
guidance is very strict as dr pouty
acknowledged today it requires
even adults who have been vaccinated to
wear masks outside at all times it
requires
uh children to be socially distanced
can you explain why that contradicts uh
the administration's guidance that
vaccinated
adults don't have to wear mass outside
and also dr fauci suggested that it may
change
as the science becomes clear but are is
the administration
at all concerned that there won't be
compliance with something this strict
and there won't be compliance if it
continuously changes
sure well first i think everyone can
expect that the guidance will continue
to be updated
and will continue to change and i think
as a parent myself of kids going to
summer school
not summer school summer camp don't tell
them i said that um
you know they uh i would welcome that uh
and there's no question what the cdc is
trying to do is provide
guidance to the american public to
parents
to families that they can trust that
they know is reliable
based on medical experts doctors based
on data
on how they can feel safe the guidance
that was
that was rolled out last week does not
convey that when you're outside
in a crowd you cannot where you should
not wear a mask
if you are outside and you're not in a
crowd then you and you're vaccinated
you don't need to wear a mask and
obviously uh there is nuance in all of
these
applications and people are still
learning how to apply it
but as kids are dropping off as parents
i should say are dropping off their kids
at summer camp
as there are tons of kids tons of
parents counselors
you know that certainly wouldn't uh
wouldn't be someone
alone but i think what dr fauci was
conveying alex is that
the data they're going to continue to
look at the data and they
want to put out updated guidance as they
feel comfortable and confident
and what they can provide to the
american public and there's a new
evaluation of the american families plan
out by the penn borton budget model
and they found actually that the plan
would increase the deficit and fail to
grow the economy
um as much as president biden has
claimed and so is
is there risk in the long term that the
president might not be able to fully
deliver what he's promised economically
well first let me say we strongly agree
disagree with the analysis as do other
independent
uh experts according to an analysis out
this week from moody's gdp in 2030 will
be more
than 700 billion dollars higher than it
would be
without the jobs and uh family the jobs
act the jobs plan and the families plan
this is in large part because labor
force participation will be nearly a
full percentage point
higher due to the effects of the
benefits of child care
child support child care support and
paid family
leave and that same analysis found that
the economic benefits would only
increase over time
due to increased college enrollment and
universal pre-k which will help some of
the two million women who are
no longer in the workforce get back in
the penn
wharton model analysis also often a
number of important ways
it gets the cost of the investments
wrong by about 700 billion dollars
even though our estimates come from
career officials at omb
moody's for example arrived at deficits
even lower
than the administration when than we had
when it came to the effect of the
family's
plan and of course our plan would be
implemented over a series of eight years
and 10 years
and paid for over 15. so we're going to
rely on the majority of economic
analysis out there and our own analysis
in here and we are confident we'll be
able to reach both our job creation
projections and
of course um do it in a way we can pay
for it one international question um
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu missed the deadline to put
together a coalition government
yesterday um or a new governing
coalition
is is the president monitoring the
situation and does the administration
have
any sort of response or perspective on
the possibility of a new coalition
government there
uh well we do read all of your news
coverage uh but uh we are not going to
comment uh publicly on government
formation
while that process is underway
go ahead andrew hey follow up on bill
and for the secretary vilsack's answer
on the twin medal saying is that a
decision that you think will be coming
at any point soon or is that just
sort of her gap i don't have a
prediction of that um i would say would
refer to the department of agriculture
and they would of course be the right
source for that information we can see
if there's more follow-up on it
on the timeline okay and then um on the
issue of
the g7 meeting and the subsequent
meetings with uh
putin have you do any news for us on
that front
um in terms of timing and also the
agenda not quite yet
as soon as we have uh details or any
confirmed
details of timing location
date participation we will of course
share that with you and i would expect
we wouldn't have more specifics on an
agenda
if and when we have it confirmed until
much closer and then just one more
on my favorite topic
[Laughter]
so this morning there was a meeting at
the wto
catherine ty made some comments during
an
ft session talking about you know time
being of the essence really sort of
underscoring
there are multiple reports out also
about
kind of a division within the
administration on this waiver issue
can you just really walk us through what
your
perspective is on this and why so that
there's so many people
in in institutions and organizations now
really putting pressure on president
biden to back this waiver
i think it's important first to just
take a step back and remind everyone
that president
the president spoke about his support uh
for
this type of a waiver back during the
campaign uh but
it it we are running a process we have
been running a process
uh in the administration uh that
includes all stakeholders in the
administration
and he is somebody who has welcomed
people of different views he wants to
know the details
he's a details guy and he wants to dig
into the pros and cons and all of the
considerations for any decision uh as we
look at this decision what we're really
talking about i know you know this
andrea but
for others um we're really talking about
the u.s position
as it relates to the wto process
right and that process will take a
series of months
and requires um a unanimous
point of view to move forward uh so what
we are the consideration now
is the u.s position our objective
overall as we look at this decision
is how can we provide as much supply
in the most cost-effective way to the
global community
and clearly there are steps we've
announced we've take we're in the
process of taking
uh providing uh 60 million doses to the
global community once we have that
available
that astrazeneca zosis earlier this week
pfizer announced
they'll also be sending doses or
manufacturing doses
for the global community and we're going
to continue to work with our partners
i expect we'll have more now that the
wto meetings are underway
we'll have more to say very soon on this
are you concerned about setting a
precedent
that could be so even if india and south
africa
narrow their proposal which is
apparently something that's going on
it may be you could ask you could
confirm that that is your understanding
um if even if that proposal is narrow
are you concerned that you're going to
be setting a precedent that could
harm u.s companies in the future which
is what you know
we hear from u.s industries well clearly
as these decisions are weighed we take
intellectual property incredibly
seriously
um and uh we also though are in the
midst of a historic global pandemic
uh which requires a range of uh creative
uh solutions um and we're looking at it
through that prism
i'm sorry jim i just want to be very
clear it sounds like you're
pushing us or leaning toward some kind
of a
a waiver of some kind i i'm not trying
to give you an indication
that obviously would be an announcement
uh or a decision that would be
recommended by the
ustr and a decision i would expect that
would be made by the ustr
uh but what i'm trying to give you an
understanding of which i think was your
question is what are the considerations
are in the thinking
and decisions will be made
uh go ahead i have questions on a couple
of different topics
the first is um on the debt limit is the
white house concerned about being able
to avoid
a government shutdown and raising the
debt limit considering the treasury's
unsure
can you how long you can use the
extraordinary measures it has
and what's the white house's strategy
for pressuring congress to agree to
raise or suspend the debt limit or
are you leaving that to treasury to
figure out well first i will say that
um on the issue at hand um raising or
suspending the debt ceiling
does not authorize new spending
sometimes i'm not saying you're confused
about that some people sometimes are
it merely allows treasury to meet
obligations that congress
has already approved so certainly they
would be in the lead as they have
historically been in most
administrations on
making that case we expect
congress to act in timely manner to
raise or suspend
the debt ceiling as they did three times
on a broad bipartisan basis
during the last administration including
the same year that the former president
signed into law tax cuts that added uh
two trillion dollars to the deficit so
we certainly expect they will move
forward
uh that this is something that has been
done in a bipartisan basis democrats and
republicans have called for it
in the past and uh that's what we'll be
advocating for
some minority leader mitch mcconnell
said this morning
when asked about kind of the issues
within his own party
um that quote 100 of my focus is on
stopping this new administration
um and he touted kind of the unity
within his caucus from
susan collins to ted cruz um are you
concerned
that it will be difficult to work with
republicans when you're
when you have these kind of statements
coming from their leader
well i guess the contrast for people to
consider is 100
of our focus is on delivering relief to
the american people
and getting the pandemic under control
and putting people back to work
and we welcome support engagement and
work with the republicans on that
and there's the president has extended
an open arm to that the door to the oval
office is open
he's invited senator capito to bring a
group of her choosing
to the white house next week and we
think there is opportunity
for agreement to deliver on
on relief to the american people one
quick question
um a judge this morning struck down the
cdc's national moratorium on eviction do
you have a response
to that in the administration's plans to
appeal potentially
yes i do we understand this just
happened as you alluded to
this morning we understand the
department of justice is reviewing the
court's decision and should have more
to say later today we also recognize of
course
the importance of the eviction
moratorium for americans who have fallen
behind on rent during the pandemic a
recent study estimates that there were
1.55 million
fewer evictions filed during 2020 than
would be expected due to the eviction
moratorium so it's clearly has it had a
huge benefit
but we would expect that a response and
any of course decision about additional
action would come from doj
and you may hear more from them today go
ahead
facebook has decided to keep former
president trump off of its platform for
now
senator ted cruz tweeted the following
for every liberal
celebrating trump's social media ban if
the big tech
oligarchs can muzzle the former
president what stop
from sensing you what do you make of
that comment does he have a point well
let me first say that um this is an
independent board's
decision uh and uh we're not gonna have
any comment
on the future of the former president's
social media platform
that's a decision that it sounds like
the independent board
punted back to facebook to make in the
next six months as i know you all have
reported
um the president's view is that
the major platforms uh have a
responsibility
related to the health and safety of all
americans to stop
amplifying untrustworthy content
disinformation and misinformation
especially related to covid19
vaccinations
and elections and we've seen that over
the past
several months broadly speaking i'm not
placing any blame on any individual or
group we've seen it from a number of
sources
he also supports better privacy
protection and a robust
anti-trust program so his view
that there's more that needs to be done
to ensure that this type of
misinformation disinformation
damaging sometimes life-threatening
information is not going out
to the american public needs to be done
are there any concerns
though about uh first amendment rights
and where does the white house draw the
line on that well look we are of course
a believer in first amendment rights i
think what the decisions are that the
social media platforms need to make is
how they address the disinformation
misinformation
especially related to life-threatening
issues like covet 19 and vaccinations
that have continue to proliferate on
their platforms i want to ask you also
jen about police reform president biden
said
he wanted it done by the first george
may 25th is he confident that congress
can meet that benchmark where do those
negotiations
well the negotiations are between
members of congress
so uh and he uh of course is confident
in
the those discussions and the work that
is happening under the leadership of
everyone from congresswoman karen bass
to senator cory booker
obviously senator tim scott who he
called out in his speech
uh just last week and we're uh we we
remain uh we are in close touch
uh with of course uh negotiators and
kept abreast of their progress
uh but we will wait to see what comes
out of those discussions do the math
though this
puts police reform in some regard ahead
of the negotiations
one would think for the american
families plan the infrastructure plan
which he set an end of the summer
deadline for
is this now the president's top priority
does he want congress to tackle this
first
well i would say that the president
believes congress can
and should move forward with multiple uh
policies at the same time and
uh certainly that that is what is
happening on capitol hill uh you know
those members who are
playing central roles in these
negotiations and obviously they can
speak to the frequency of the
discussions and the status of them and
defer to them they will be important
participants of course in any outcome
of negotiations around the american jobs
plan but
those negotiations can happen
simultaneously just finally
jen how does he see his role and he's
the one making this call to get this
done has he reached out to tim scott the
person who's leading the charge on the
gop
i don't have any calls or engagements to
read out to you
uh but i can say that as you know a
number of representatives of the
families were here just last week
meeting with some senior members of the
white house leadership
uh the president has talked about how
it's long overdue
to put in place uh police reform
measures that
that will help rebuild trust in our
communities he used his joint session
speech the highest profile moment uh in
a first in a president's first year
to talk about that and make the case and
uh but the negotiations are happening
between members of congress
he feels that's the appropriate place
for them to be and we will continue to
uh use opportunities to call for this
moving forward
uh go ahead kristen hi kristen kristen
kristen i got confused caitlyn
there's a lot of k's it's a wednesday go
ahead right chris and i also been
dressing the light lately so it's fine
justin has a very good mask on today
both of your masks go ahead okay my
question is on these restaurant
funds when will they start being awarded
and does the president envision
having to ask congress for more money
for this well on the second piece
um well first the first awards as part
of the pilot program will
be funded friday so receive this program
not the pilot
the the actual part of it not the pilot
those who applied this week
can expect up to uh up to 14 days on
average from submission to funding so
it'll be a very rapid turnaround
okay in disenvision asking congress for
more money for this
when congress comes back we are happy to
discuss the best ways to further support
small businesses including restaurants
hurt by the crisis so he's certainly
open to that
and as i noted there has already been a
large interest
in this pro um and there are great needs
across the country from these small
businesses from these restaurants that
are uh in communities across the country
so we will we're happy to have a
conversation with congress about that
okay and my question on the patents you
were talking about how the president
last summer expressed his favor for
waving these so countries would be able
to mass produce
these vaccines once they're ready of
course that was when they were not ready
yet last summer
so just to be clear is that still his
position
that has been that has been his position
he also believes that there needs to be
an internal policy
process that's what's been ongoing the
recommendation the appropriate process
the recommendation to come
from the ustr and then any announcement
about a decision would come from usdr
and that's how government
should function and should work and as
and i noted in response to andrew's
question
there are of course considerations uh
but we're also uh in the midst of a
global pandemic and we are
our objective is to getting as much
supply
out into the global community as as
quickly as possible in the most cost
effective manner as we can
but what did he communicate to catherine
ty his trade representative
before these meetings with the wto on
this
are underway well there have been
discussions happening here uh
in a through a policy process i don't
think his comments he made last summer
are a secret
um they're certainly not but again he's
a believer that you need to have a
party at the table everyone providing
information
hearing details pros and cons of every
decision
uh and that's exactly what he asked for
from his policy teams
so given what he's heard from the policy
teams from the health experts
like dr falchi have weighed in publicly
about whether this would be helpful
in making vaccines right now or that
would be further down the road but is
his position
still what he said last summer which is
absolutely positively
he will ensure there are no patents
standing in the way of other countries
and companies
mass producing these life-saving
vaccines that has been his position
but he is the president of the united
states who believes in the advice the
council the considerations of his policy
teams
uh and that has been the process that's
been ongoing over the last several weeks
and i expect we'll have more to say
quite soon it's also important to note
just
just in response to one of the things
you said that uh this is not
this would not be this is about the us
position there would be an entire
process at the wto
that would be likely be months uh in the
making uh and that's just how the
process works so there's also a
consideration leading up to that
okay thank you okay good thank you jen
yesterday you said that the cdc engaged
with around 50 stakeholders when coming
up with these guidelines for rio yeah
school
so in addition to the teachers union the
american federation of teachers
who are these other roughly 50
stakeholders well let me give you
i'm not going to read all 50. you know
but and i'm happy to send them to you
after um but just as an example while i
find this lengthy list
you know they include the ymca they
include
the council of chief state school
officers the national association of
school nurses the national governors
association
big cities health coalition autism
speaks
council of great city schools uh so
there's a range of
organizations and as we were talking
about yesterday the objective is to have
a better understanding of implementation
uh how it would work and ensure that
these guidelines can be implemented and
they would not provide harm to the
communities that they would be impacting
but can you just explain maybe just a
little bit more you know why
the cdc needs all of this input from so
many outside entities why can't it just
come up with these
science-based guidelines on its own they
do so
to ensure that the recommendations are
feasible to implement and that they
adequately address
the safety and well-being of individuals
the guidance is aimed to protect and
that type of consultation is pretty
standard as a part of their
consideration processes
one other topic sure right now there is
a huge
chinese rocket in outer space that's
going to be crashing down to earth
likely on saturday and nobody knows
exactly where it'll likely be in an
ocean but it could or pieces of it could
come down over a populated area this
isn't the first time that
china has allowed knowingly allowed
something like this to happen
so does the white house condemn this
kind of repeated reckless behavior from
china's space program well let me first
say that u.s space command
is aware of and tracking the location of
the chinese long march 5b
in space and obviously the space command
would have more specifics on that
tracking
and an additional details the united
states is committed to
addressing the risks of growing
congestion due to space debris and
growing
activity in space and we want to work
with the international community to
promote leadership and responsible
space behaviors it's in the shared
interests of all nations to act
responsibly in space to ensure the
safety stability
security and long-term sustainability of
outer space
activities so cooperation is a hallmark
of our approach
we're going to work with our
international partners on that
and certainly addressing this is
something we'll do through those
channels
just a quick follow-up if this rocket
does cause some serious damages here on
earth
would the white house enforce china
paying some sort of compensation as
required by the u.n
liability space liability convention
well um again i think we'd
of course uh refer to the advice and uh
guidance from u.s space command and
department of defense and others
but we're not at this point we're
certainly tracking its location
uh through u.s space command and uh
hopefully that's not the outcome that we
are working through
okay go ahead eli thanks jim um i'm just
interested if you have any response to
some of the moves made this week by a
few republican governors to
get rid of you know protections that
were in place for people public benefits
also
public health restrictions uh basically
sending the message that the pandemic is
over
and sort of uh criticizing washington
the cdc uh
bureaucrats as ron desantis put it for
telling people they still need to wear
masks indoors
uh those sorts of things saying the
vaccines have worked
how are you trying to thread that needle
by celebrating the progress of
all the people who have been vaccinated
and keeping these things in place and
also
trying to keep people from viewing this
through a political lens any outreach to
any of these
republican state officials about the
message they're sending uh and any
response to them from the podium
sure well first we not only do a regular
a governor's call
every single week with governors from
across the country from red states and
blue states to talk about
implementation any changes we're making
to allocations as we talked about just
yesterday
but we also have regular engagement with
governors and local officials
about where the public health guidance
is going
uh questions they have and even
sometimes challenges they have
in their communities our position from
the federal government continues to be
that the public health guidelines
are in place to keep people safe not
just
governors and leaders of states of
course but people in communities
families kids people who are in
vulnerable populations
and that we'll continue to communicate
that from the federal level even as
governors
are pulling back uh their implementation
in some places where it might be
premature
the president yesterday was talking
about transitioning from the mass
vaccination centers largely in urban and
suburban areas and trying to
really be more deliberate proactive
about getting the vaccine to
people in outlying areas rural areas is
there any concern about having enough
vaccinators
uh to reach people in those areas will
this mostly be run through
local pharmacies or is there going to be
a similar effort to
authorize different people and sort of
medical fields
to be able to administer vaccines well
we did take that step
some time ago to expand the um
type of individuals who are qualified to
be vaccinators because early on we
recognized that
it wasn't just about supply it was also
about locations and obviously
as you alluded to we've made some
changes and adjustments
but also about vaccinators and ensuring
that a larger group of individuals
dentists veterinarians others
could also be eligible to do the vaccine
and get into people's arms because we
want to ensure that
in a range of communities across the
country there's a range of options for
people who can do
exactly that uh so that's not a concern
that
uh we are tracking at this point in time
a lack of because we did a lot of work
preparing
uh for those needs and i would say that
um you know there were some
mass vaccination sites we opened even
last
week but what we announced yesterday is
a
kind of a phased approach based on the
phase we're in uh at this point in time
which is
uh that we are recognizing the daily
numbers will go down a bit because we're
at such
a high percentage rate relative to where
people thought we were at this point in
the pandemic
and we know it will be harder and harder
to reach people and meet people where
they are
hence the increase as you suggested in
walk-in hours or the announcement of
walk-in hours
on mobile units on partnerships with
primary care physicians and doctors
to make it even easier and more
accessible for people to get the vaccine
this one more on tomorrow on the trip to
louisiana so far
the president has mostly traveled to
states that are you know competitive
swing states louisiana is obviously a
red state but has been impacted by
suffered texas and ohio okay but i mean
there's been a lot of travel to some of
these things can you just talk a little
bit about the
the takeaway that people should have
when they see the president showing up
you know deeper at louisiana tomorrow on
the issues that he wants to
draw attention to sure well first the
president when he was elected uh
knew from day one he was going to govern
for all americans and that was going to
be his objective
and so even if it's for people who
didn't vote for him for states who
didn't vote for him
his uh focus is on delivering for them
so tomorrow uh he'll make two stops in
louisiana uh his focus will be on
talking about
the american jobs plan and how that plan
in a historic investment in
infrastructure rebuilding the type of
bridges
roads in louisiana that are long overdue
to be upgraded
could help not only people's travel and
commutes
but also create jobs in these
communities and uh it's not about
just delivering for people who voted for
him or people who have uh blue check
marks next to their name
because they're democrats and that's uh
part of what this message should chan
this visit should send go ahead i get
that you sort of prefer the moody's
model over the pen wharton
i'm just curious the white house is
going to accept whatever cbo
and jct scores the president's proposals
at
well i think our issue with the penn
morton model was the data it was based
on and that it was off
and so we'll have to look at what the
data that any of future analysis is
based on and then we'll give an
assessment okay so even
official you're not embracing whatever
the official assessment will be from cbo
and jct well hans there is no assessment
at this point in time our assumption is
that they would be abiding by accurate
data so we'll look forward to seeing
those assessments
when do you expect those assumptions and
data to come in
i don't have a prediction of that i
suggest you ask them
go ahead alex uh does president biden
agree with governor whitmer's decision
on the oil and gas pipeline she's citing
essentially water quality issues uh it's
really angered canada
does president biden agree with that
decision uh i'd have to take a closer
look at the pipeline i mean we have been
evaluating in a case-by-case scenario
which which pipeline are talking about
the enbridge the average one
uh we look at each pipeline uh through
the prism of the impact on the
environment
and also the economy uh and we
assessments so i'd have to talk to the
team if the assessment has been
concluded or not
okay and the president's gonna be
talking about implementation later
what sort of oversight uh plans
are being talked about as far as the
spending and making sure it's
for the restaurant program or just the
programs in general in general
inspector generals i mean can you give
us an idea what sort of oversight is
being talked about
well first uh the president uh came into
this job having served
uh as the person overseeing the
implementation of the american
uh rescue and recovery uh the ara arra
uh back in the early days of the obama
by administration he takes waste fraud
and abuse incredibly
seriously and we have put in place uh
changes and reforms to programs at sba
and other
programs that have been implemented
where we've seen
incidents of that in the past it's also
why he has somebody
gene sperling overseeing the american
rescue plan implementation to ensure
there is
coordination across government that we
are tracking
uh where we see issues and certainly
he's somebody who
welcomes oversight and wants to do
everything we can to reduce any wasteful
abuse in these programs and just finally
i wonder if the president or anyone was
in the administration uh with the
treasury secretary yesterday given
some of her remarks that she then
something clarified
well the secretary herself uh addressed
her remarks later in the afternoon so
i'm not aware of any
calls yesterday um she will be here in
the briefing room and they'll have their
regular economic briefing on friday
go in the back so i want to talk about
climate for a second
um the president had said in his
executive order
in january that he would call for a
green procurement plan for the federal
government
and part of that was about buying
electric cars
the deadline for that plan was april
27th
do you know what the status of it is and
why the delay
uh i don't have an update on the status
it is something as you noted he talked
about registration he's absolutely
committed
but i'm happy to check with the team and
see where our
uh report on that lives and
um i also asked does the barton
administration have a timeline
at this point for issuing pardons and
computations
uh i don't have any uh previewing of
that to provide
and probably won't from here uh go in
the back
uh yes is the los angeles mayor eric
garcettian
under active consideration to be the
ambassador
to india or any other country
i don't have any personnel announcements
or assessments to make
here uh from the podium but hopefully
we'll have some more formal
announcements on ambassadors soon
and the tokyo olympics are 12 weeks
out at what point does the president
need to make a decision
about his attendance his attendance
and his and what factors are delaying
the announcement
well i think the president uh and his
team assess any invitation
as it comes in but 12 weeks is some
period of time i don't have any
updates or predictions on whether or not
he'll travel or
accept the invitation made to attend the
olympics go ahead
thanks jen uh two questions first on
uh the large sports arenas that are
beginning to allow
uh fully vaccinated fans in special
sections uh both uh citi field and
yankee stadium in new york have made
those announcements and i know there are
some
others does the administration think
that that is
a good approach for uh sports teams to
take
and maybe other large event venues and
are there any concerns
about uh equity when it comes to
access to facilities if particularly
that were built with some public money
in some cases i'm sure
uh when it comes to people who may not
have been able to get vaccinated yet
well first everyone in the country is
eligible to be vaccinated and certainly
at this point in time so we are and we
as we've noted here have taken
a range of steps to ensure we are
meeting people we are getting these
vaccine doses out to communities
around the country uh in terms of an
assessment of the safety of
this approach by sports teams i'd have
to talk to our coveted team
about that and i think it's unlikely
we're going to be weighing into every
private sector decision
about how they're uh moving forward uh
once people are vaccinated but i will
check with them
on that okay and then the other the
other question if i can follow up on the
uh
the definite question just a little bit
sure has there
does it does the president have a
position on whether or not the debt
limit itself
should exist at all considering every
every
you know couple of years we go through
this question of
what are the extraordinary measures and
how much extra time do we have and we
know at the end of the day that
it's going to have to get raised or else
we're going to have some sort of
economic
calamity does the president have a view
on the question
more broadly of whether or not there
even should be a debt limit
well first raising or suspending the
debt ceiling doesn't authorize
new spending it merely allows treasury
to meet obligations that congress has
already approved
right it has been the case for many
years
um and there have been bipartisan votes
to support
um so you know the president does
believe that
treasurer should be able to meet its
obligations and believes that
mood in a bipartisan manner as they have
historically in the past including three
times during the prior administration
go in the back uh thanks um on the g7
trip um is there any advance on whether
the president will meet with the queen
and uh separately um how's the president
or first lady
been in contact recently with prince
harry
i don't have any more trip details um
who among us
want to go see the queen but i don't
have any details to
preview at this point in time i expect
as we get closer to the trip we'll have
more specifics
um and uh i don't have any calls or
engagements uh
with prince harry or uh meghan markle to
uh
to read out for you with the president
or the first lady
is there is there a timeline on an
announcement for the british ambassador
a timeline i don't have a timeline for
that
any names or any anyone no names to
float out there for you
uh hopefully we'll have some more
ambassadors soon to announce
when he says soon will that be before
after he makes his decision on going to
the olympics
i can't order for you hans there's just
so much excitement to stay tuned for
around here so
we'll see okay thanks everyone
you